coming up so you do your first two
fights and then ufc 2011 i think you
start going into ufc you're coming up at
what point did the world kind of realize
this this guy's legit what was the one
fight that you had when everybody
started saying he's legit i had a unique
opportunity coming from the wec
when i was signed to the wec ufc bought
the company so they merged all the
fighters onto their roster
and a guy named jose aldo if you're a
fight fan you know legendary world
champion jose aldo is he was getting
ready to fight a guy named josh grisby
on a new year's card in the mgm grand in
las vegas and jose hurt his neck and
they needed like a tune-up keep the guy
ready for when jose is healthy and they
called me
and
i actually got the call i was in the gym
training on the mats when i got the call
so i was in the right spot
and they asked me to cut down to 145
pounds for this opportunity to fight the
number one contender what were you at
that time when they called you i was
fighting at 155 pounds but i was
probably 180 something so you had to cut
down 30
45 pounds mm-hmm
yeah 120
that's right 25 people yeah but when
dana white calls you and you're a young
kid and this is going to be your first
fight in the ufc you say yes 155 or 145.
this one was 145. i've never made that
in my in my my career as a fighter
amateur or a pro until that call
when when those fights happen does a
dana call or does somebody on dana's
team call your camp and say hey is he
ready to fight
usually it's somebody um
in the office at the ufc but on these
kind of things dana will call so dana
calls
and then who comes and tells you hey you
got a big fight potentially coming was i
was in the gym so my coach my buddy tim
who was on the ultimate fighter came and
said hey it's happening you're going to
the ufc and we kind of knew that because
the company bought the wc got it so we
knew we were going to be merged over but
i didn't know it was going to be that
soon you know i might have had a few
weeks to prepare but i went in there and
you asked me when i felt like i got on
the scene i went in there and i
unanimous decision
over the number one contender at 145
pounds it's pretty sick and made a big
splash yeah and that's 10 years ago you
were 21 years old yeah
guys that's pretty insane if you do
something like that
okay so now you leave
now you're saying what's the are you
thinking are you talking to guys saying
hey listen sky's the limit for us right
now what are you thinking at that moment
that win out of all the wins i've won um
the interim championship when i beat max
holloway in atlanta sick thanks and uh
that that first win getting my hand
raised in the ufc for the first time
is still one of the
best feelings most memorable feelings
that i've had because i always thought i
could compete with those guys
but to go in there and beat the number
one contender on short notice i felt
like everything was stacked against me
it really felt like all right like i can
do anything here i can be the world
champion
i mean of course i mean if you're going
at a
with a guy like that at 21 years old
you're not even at your prime yet what
age in this business is prime
everybody's different genetics but for
me the way i look at it is uh you start
off with
your athletic ability to be high and
fighting is so mental it's it's not only
your skill set and fighting everybody
punches hard everybody's fast at this
level we're all great athletes everybody
works their ass off it's it's there's a
there's a prime moment where the
athletics here and the minds here
and you start to age and and it comes
down and and when they even out that's
when you're in your prime and
everybody's different but now is my time
right now you're at your prime right now
yeah you're looking at it
oh man
so right now like
you know who do you think you can go up
against and when is there any is there
any fight that you would like to see
happen where you're fighting
i'm just waiting on the contract that
looks like i'm going to be fighting for
the lightweight world championship
december 11th in las vegas
yeah and it's against against charles
oliveira really yeah that's not it's not
been signed yet though it's not been
signed let they actually leaked the news
yesterday so it's starting to get out
there but uh i've agreed to it december
11th i'm going to be the world champion
very cool well we're definitely looking
forward to that so if you like this sort
of short clip from an interview i did
click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]